Homefront no revolution coming out of
Gamescom with a demo that showed off a
lot of the sort of a glimpse of the open
world stuff and a sweet motorcycle here
to talk about that game Aaron Sampson
and Mike McCarty hi guys how's it going
hey oh it's going good pretty
entertaining press conference there was
some decent games on show nothing to
blow you away but I was personally
interested in homefront the revolution I
kind of like that game a bunch even
though it like ended I don't know
two-thirds of the way ended way too
early yeah they just kind of got to the
Golden Gate Bridge and they're like yeah
we won good job guys yeah the bridge the
city now don't worry about it we'll talk
about that later homefront the
revolution obviously switching coasts
and advancing the timeline a little bit
now you're in Philadelphia now the
Korean People's Army is not invading
they are occupying full-on across the
United States and this demo started
we're getting a look now at the sort of
motorcycle driving in the which like
here's the question I'm asking how big
is this world that this person is
driving through could you take a left
and a right and drive off into some
direction with this motorcycle or is it
like basically you got to go this way
yeah I was kind of looking through this
footage it seems like at least in this
mission they're channeling in a large
arena and it looked like the map did
have boundaries but when I was reading
up on homefront the Revolution it seems
like they're going more the far cry for
route you have main missions and then
you can go on these side quests and
liberate strike points essentially
and then you know the map does that
reveal and some of the things that it
showed there was an ammo cache there was
a kPa stronghold so yeah really
channeling that open-world vibe of like
the Far Cry see yeah like this sort of
outpost attacks in Far Cry you know you
sort of work your way in and pick them
off and take them down but in this one
it seems like you work your way in to
get a foothold you do that kind of
hacking thing real quick and then a
bunch of new missions open up in the
area allowing you to sort of it says I
think establish a presence because like
guerrilla warfare is what this you know
what this game is all about and that's
always a tricky one with a first-person
shooter because you want to be the guy
who's just shooting everyone in a
first-person shooter but here it seemed
and you certainly are in this one but
there's also there's crafting there's
aking seems like there's a little bit
more to in play it's interesting one of
the other things that we just saw there
was also weapon hot swapping like
getting scopes and attachments on and
off of your weapon yeah I know that
Crytek had a little bit of a hand in
this game and I previously saw that in
their war face games so I wonder if I
think I crisis had it a little bit too
yeah yeah totally I think that they you
know that was watching our e3 demo from
2014 actually and they're saying you
know it's in our DNA a little bit of
course we're gonna do this weapon
customization stuff so yeah that was
definitely on display here with the yeah
I'm just gonna like put on a new scope
I've got that in my pocket that was in
modern warfare 3 if I recall correctly
as well that was like a big driving
force with modern warfare 3 that said
look you can do this on the go and that
was a huge selling point I guess yeah
that would be really cool if this ends
up in there multiplayer they just hinted
that their multiplayer and they said
something about you being able to team
up with your friends and I like in
faction or crew which hopefully is more
than just you friending up with somebody
at like I hope that there's a little bit
more of a story there are you thinking
more of something like a long life of
the division maybe where you've got you
know sort of multiple teams vying for a
same objective although I guess that
would really make sense a narrative Lee
in homefront in the what cuz you've
basically got two sides maybe more lions
and the Last of Us where you get status
updates that your friend is not off the
face of a raccoon or build a fence or
got dysentery that was like the best
Facebook integration that any game has
ever had but Aaron the multiplayer is
something that you and I enjoyed a quite
a bit in homefront and what was the
defining thing there that really sort of
separated it was you you earn these
battle points through your actions and
then there's like a pretty broad array
of drones you can bring to bear yeah the
drone warfare was quite good and that's
one of the things I actually showed here
and the trailer was the guy driving the
RC car bomb all that stuff made it into
multiplayer there were aerial drones and
ground drones and it was cool because it
you know it extended your life in the
game you know instead of just running in
with your guns blazing you could
actually set up a good strategic moves
and your drone in first and have it mess
things up there'd also like this single
player had some really large drones that
more main characters in the game but
yeah the the drone aspect I think that
came
from frontlines fuels of war that's
where the mechanics came from for that
not only that but they also had a lot of
personality which I like to the
personality said like the drones or just
in general like in general you've got
that beat up revolution so the drones
had personality and then the I think the
weapons especially in this demo we saw
were a little bit more beat up and you
know you have a better sense of time in
place of a battle and I posted generic
mixed soldier do you yeah and I think
that was one of the strengths of the
homefront series right is setting the
mood setting a time in place and
certainly the trailer they showed at
Gamescom with that little kid giving the
like forced speech and you know
propaganda speech in front of the
assembled army generals and whatnot
there it looks like they're gonna be
leaning even more into this this sort of
this setting Mike this is a tricky
setting though because you're basically
playing as a terrorist in your own
country yeah because in the first game
being on the west coast it was it was
kind of unsettling because you are
rising up against these you know these
governing forces that have since taken
over there's a plague that comes into
play somewhere before the storyline the
first one and obviously now they're
going to the East Coast which is
exciting for me because that was always
a cool setting to me I think that's
something the Last of Us also kind of
satisfied that futuristic dystopian in
the Last of Us case it was
post-apocalyptic but it's kind of cool
to see the America we know in a
different setting and now that they're
on the East Coast I'm excited because my
home turf but it'll be cool to see how
they handle that especially because like
Aaron said for multiplayer and
singleplayer
you know they were kind of going off
frontline there work on frontline zeal
of war and it'll be kind of cool to see
how they iterate since you know the
original game has gotten maybe not aged
so well I'm curious to see how they do
with the sequel and what new like sort
of gut-wrenching
stunts they pull hiding in a mass grave
I don't think I've ever done that in any
other video game except for homefront
that's homefront the revolution coming
out 2016 I think is the general time
period so we'll see how that shapes up
in the coming months